- The only k-pop I know
is PSY in Gangnam Style.
- I know how to say squirrel.
- I don't expect them to do too well.
- This would be easier with like, a shot.
- [Voiceover] Park Jae-Sang.
- I didn't know PSY I
wasn't his real name.
I feel like everything is a lie.
- Ooh.
- Pok-Jay-Sang.
- Pok-Jay-Song.
- It's like, they're like
doing this sound that,
maybe it's like not natural to English.
Park-jya-song?
- Pok-Jay-Song.
It sounded right to me.
- [Voiceover] Ok Taec-Yeon.
- Okay?
It's not okay, though.
Oh?
Um, one of these letters is solid.
- O-Kay-Taw-Kyoon.
- Oh-Kay Tayk-Yone.
Oh Take-On?
- Awk-Ty-Awk.
I can't get my head straight.
- A lot of times my mind will
translate it to English for me
so it'd be like oh tech young,
And that's like, probably not the way
to approach this at all.
- I would just call the person OK.
- [Voiceover] Kim Jong-Hyun.
- I would have said Shin-Ee.
It's shiny?
- Kim Jong-Un.
- Oh, that's a K.
Oh, we're doing a K-Pop star.
- Kim...
Kim Jong-Yun?
- Kim Jong Choon.
- It's another one of those
H's that sneaks in there.
Kim Jong-Hine.
- Kim Hong-Yoon?
- Kim Jong-Hime.
I'm done. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] Jung Ji-Hoon.
- Rain, Rain's a cool name.
- Wong-EE-Hone?
- Yung-Jee-Hoon.
- Ooh, I was so far off.
- Jong-Jee-Hoon?
- The J's are not J's.
- Jung-Jee-Yoon.
- Jon-Chee-Choon?
- [Voiceover] Kim Heechul.
- [Man] Super Junior.
That's like opposites.
That's like, fat-skinny. Super Junior.
- Kim Hee-Kool.
- Kim Heechul.
- It's like a ch.
Kim Heechul.
- Kim-EE-Choo.
Chool.
That's the hardest thing
I've ever heard in my life.
- [Voiceover] Bae Su-ji.
- Is B-E-I Bae?
Or Bai?
- Bae Su-ji.
- Oh, Soo-Chee. Chee.
- I'm used to saying like
bae as in like my bae.
Beh, beh, beh.
Let's try this slower. Bae-Sooh-Ji
I think that was good.
- We think it's pretty good,
it's not pretty good though.
- [Voiceover] Kwon Ji Yong.
- [Man] G-Dragon.
I've actually heard of this
guy, he's pretty popular.
- Kwon Ji Yong.
Yong, Yong.
- Oh yeah, the oh, oh.
- Yong.
- I'm not even gonna try that.
- [Voiceover] Lee Chae-Rin.
- [Woman] 2ne1?
I know about these girls.
Those girls right?
- Lee Chae-rin.
Leh, Lee-Chay-Reen.
- Lee Chy-Rin.
- Lee Chae-rin.
Lee Chae-rin?
- EE-Teh-In.
- The solid L, that's
just throwing me off.
- [Voiceover] Park Chanyeol.
- [Woman] Exo.
Oh, EE-Ex-Oh.
- Park Chan-EE-Ole?
- Oh, no, no, let me try again.
Park Chanyeol.
I don't know.
- I don't hear the R's being pronounced.
So it's like Pok-Chon-Yaw?
- Pok-Chon-Yaw.
Ooh, that last part's so hard.
- I literally can't hear it, it's science.
- I don't think I did very well at all.
- My lips weren't able to move
like they were supposed to.
- I can't trust anything or anyone anymore
knowing that PSY isn't his real name.
- I hope I offended nobody.
- I think these are very pretty names.
I apologize for butchering them.
- You know, people pronounce
my name wrong all the time.
My name's Gary.
- PSY is my favorite because I feel like
he's just whacky and cool and that's
why he appeals to people.
I guess we all have a
little bit of weird in us.